[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous nous allons
évoquer ici des sujets stratégiques et
sur ces dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous une
interprétation au delà des péripéties
intérieur de la présidence de donald
trump il soir gardera certainement en
mémoire sa réorganisation du
moyen-orient avec les accords d'abraham
qui change les équilibres stratégiques
après 50 ans d'immobilisme dans cette
région complexe
le président américain ne voulait pas
faire la guerre n'est d'ailleurs pas
intervenues en iran malgré les pressions
de ses conseillers distant des lobby
militaro industriels et pétroliers
ils avaient pour objectif déclaré de
ramener ses soldats sur le sol américain
et ne voulait pas devoir être le garant
militaire d'un moyen orient déchiré par
les crises pour lui comme pour son
gendre jared kushner la prise du pouvoir
par les frères musulmans ou leurs alliés
avec l'aide du qatar lors de ce qu'on a
appelé le printemps arabe n'avait réussi
qu'en turquie avec deux échecs semblant
en libye et en syrie et trois évolutions
raté en tunisie en egypte et à bahreïn
comme l'a écrit finbarr aurélie de
'reuters' faute des lidd politique
capable de prendre la relève et en
raison du heyritz islamistes l'espoir a
vite été déçus d'autre part toutes les
tentatives de rapprochement entre israël
et ses voisins ayant échoué il était le
seul à pouvoir créer les conditions
d'une paix durable grâce à ses relations
différentes mais très solide avec tous
les acteurs
son unique ennemi est temps l'iran il a
commencé par le déstabiliser en
dénonçant le 8 mai 2018
l'accord nucléaire existant signé par
tous les occidentaux ou presque et la
russie et la chine
et puis en installant le blocus
économique le plus dur de l'histoire
pour l'amener à négocier
depuis sa création en 1948 israël est en
conflit ouvert avec tous ses voisins ou
presque après la guerre des six jours en
1967 qui lui a permis de conquérir gaza
la cisjordanie il plateau du golan
il a mis en place une politique
permanente de colonisation sur jérusalem
et en six journées
parallèlement il a maintenu une armée de
haut niveau pour se défendre et effectué
des raids pour répondre à tout type de
menace
totalement isolée du reste du
moyen-orient en dehors de la jordanie et
de l'égypte israël possède depuis les
années 70 l'arme nucléaire avec l'aide
initial de la france il n'a jamais
hésité à faire éliminer par le mossad
les personnes pouvant présenter un
risque pour sa sécurité
qu'il soit terroriste ou ingénieur
depuis 1967
les etats unis soutiennent totalement la
politique d'israël avec lequel ils ont
tissé des liens très étroits ils les ont
utilisés en 1985 dans la r and get pour
faire transiter de l'armement vers
l'iran par israël pays devenu depuis
l'ennemi prioritaire d'israël
quand il a décidé de se doter lui aussi
de l'armé nucléaire
la situation de blocage actuelle a pour
origine le vote par l'onu de la
résolution 242 exigent le retour aux
frontières de 1967 et le statut de ville
ouverte pour jérusalem qui sont devenus
avec le temps passait totalement
irréalisable tous les premiers ministres
israéliens ont clairement refusé
d'appliquer cette résolution
certains pays arabes ont mis l'accent
sur l'importance de la ville sacrée de
l'islam d'où le prophète mohammed fils
ascension vers les cieux
sur sa jument al boraq d'autres se sont
mobilisés sur la gestion et la question
des réfugiés et de leur retour
tous se sont focalisés sur les
conditions de vie des palestiniens de
gaza ou de cisjordanie pour débloquer la
situation
trump a brisé plusieurs tabous en
s'opposant à la résolution 242 de l'onu
et en décidant que jérusalem serait la
capitale d'israël
il a reconnu ce qui était devenu une
réalité sur le terrain depuis juillet
2000 où il ya sert arafat n'avait pas
voulu prendre le risque de signer un bon
accord car c'était un bon accord avec le
premier ministre ehud barak
aucun des dirigeants palestiniens ayant
fait la moindre proposition le président
trump a laissé tomber les palestiniens
il a ensuite convaincu israël que pour
obtenir une paix durable
comme l'expliquent très bien l'embase
l'ex ambassadeur marocain ahmad fawzi
il devait sortir de la diplomatie
tactique fonder sur les rapports de
force pour trouver un terrain d'entente
sur les problèmes de fond enfin il s'est
appuyé sur l'évolution de la situation
depuis la proposition de paix arabe de
2002 incluant la reconnaissance d'israël
que ce dernier avait d'ailleurs rejeté
il a ainsi amené les pays voisins à
négocier directement la paix sous le
parapluie américain en utilisant la
pression et les incitations économiques
et financières ce virage à 180 degrés
par rapport à l'existant 1 certes
choqués par la méthode mais a été une
réussite
les émirats arabes unis devenu un suisse
du moyen orient après l'effondrement du
libre sont avant tout des pragmatiques 7
places financières où la rigueur des
réglementations européennes ne
s'applique pas accueil des gens de
toutes origines du bail est un carrefour
d'affaires international qui fait du
commerce avec touches et 8 milliards de
dollars annuels de contrebande avec
l'iran tout proche selon la revue monde
afrique
abou dhabi à la gestion rigoureuse et
orientée vers l'avenir
s'opposent aux frères musulmans les
américains les ont encouragés à se
rapprocher d'israël en l'accompagnant
par la vente d'armements très performant
ils ont aussi garanti que d'autres états
ferait de même
ce qui leur évitait d'être accusé de
trahison il est d'ailleurs intéressant
de noter que moins d'un mois après
l'ouverture des relations diplomatiques
une ligne aérienne a été mise en place
entre dubai et tel aviv est
qu'aujourd'hui les hôtels émirati sont
remplis d'hommes d'affairé israël pour
l'arabie saoudite gardienne des lieux
saints du sunnisme et initiatrice du
wahhabisme la version rigoriste de
l'islam qui s'opposent aux frères
musulmans
l'ennemi est clairement l'iran
représentants du chiisme considérée
comme une religion déviante de surcroît
l'iran dans sa volonté expansionniste
prend des positions stratégiques au
liban avec le hezbollah en syrie avec
les gardiens de la révolution et en irak
pays en une frontière commune avec
l'arabie où les partis chiites sont
majoritaires
pire encore pour les saoudiens au yémen
qu'ils considèrent comme leur domaine
réservé les iraniens soutiennent et
inspire les outils en interne
le royaume a depuis longtemps un vrai
problème de gouvernance
les princes plus ou moins corrompus
s'opposent entre eux et la population ne
profite pas des revenus du pétrole les
états unis devenus autosuffisants
grâce à la production de pétrole et de
gaz de schiste chez eux n'ont plus
besoin des saoudiens alors que ceux ci
on entend encore besoin le temps de
faire évoluer le pays
c'est l'objectif du prince mohammed bin
salman dont la brutalité dans
l'assassinât de jamal khashoggi en
turquie vous en souvenez est loin
d'avoir provoqué de véritables
représailles diplomatiques
au delà des agitations médiatiques en
peu de temps
le prince a mis au pas les autres
princes leurs conseillers et développe
des investissements lourds pour aider la
population et la faire bénéficier du
changement dans cette affaire le soutien
américain au niveau militaire
la contribution aux achats pétroliers et
l'aide face à la menace iranienne sont
évidemment prioritaire par rapport au
problème palestinien
la seule raison qui empêche la signature
avec israël res le statut de jérusalem
est un lieu saint de l'islam
avec le qatar pays semblables ont
beaucoup plus petit à l'arabie saoudite
le problème est très différent il
partage avec l'iran le plus grand
gisement gazier du monde restait deux
ans et demi sous embargo économique
saoudien et des pays du golfe pour son
appui aux frères musulmans dont ils
propagent des idées par la chaîne de
télévision al djazira il a fait preuve
d'une forte résilience avec l'aide de la
turquie
le problème ayant été réglé par l'accord
du 5 janvier dans lequel il faut bien
dire les états unis associé au koweit
ont joué un rôle essentiel
il cesse d'être isolé il va pouvoir
revenir dans le comité de coordination
des états arabes du golfe
faut dire que la présence dans le pays
d'une des deux plus grosses bases
militaires américaines au moyen-orient a
joué un rôle dans cette réconciliation
mais toujours décidé à aider les
palestiniens en plan financier
humanitaire le qatar ne veut pas signer
un accord avec israël tant qu'on n'aura
pas solutionner leurs cas à bahreïn
royaume à majorité chiite
la famille régnante qui est allié aux
saoudiens a ratifié des accords d'abrams
comme le soudan et le maroc au koweït et
à oman qui sont resté neutre dans le
conflit entre les émirats l'arabie
saoudite et le qatar
on veut pouvoir commercer échangé avec
tout le monde
iran compris l'egypte quant à elle est
en paix avec israël depuis l'initiative
du président sadate et les accords de 79
qui lui ont coûté la vie l'idée de
remplacer le président moubarak par un
frère musulman a été totalement rejetée
par la population ce qui a permis aux
militaires de reprendre leurs bonnes
habitudes en désignant comme remplaçant
le maréchal si si le pays est en lutte
contre les frères avec l'appui de
l'arabie saoudite et contre les
terroristes islamiques venue en partie
de gaza
le ressentiment égyptiens contre les
américains la pousser à relancer la
coopération en particulier militaires
avec les russes souvenons nous de
l'achat des bateaux français qu'on
devait vendre aux russes ceux qui ont
été repris par les égyptiens
au-delà du problème terroriste
essentiellement dans le sinaï l'egypte
est confronté à deux menaces venant de
pays proches
les infiltrations terroristes venus de
libye dont il contrôle la frontière
commune
en aidant le maréchal haftar la
construction par l'ethiopie du plus
grand barrage hydroélectrique d'afrique
qui va perturber l'approvisionnement en
eau du soudan puis de l'egypte qui je le
rappelle dépendent huile à 97% pour son
agriculture
comme l'a écrit récemment le point
afrique tu 5 janvier
la turquie reste avec le qatar un des
derniers soutiens des palestiniens mais
cela l'a pas empêché de développer avis
qu israël d'importants échanges
commerciaux le problème turc est à la
fois interne externe
l'économie va mal malgré le
développement du commerce avec la russie
en substitution de l'embargo fait par
l'union européenne suite à l'affairé
l'ukrainienne d'autre part la répression
de la tentative de coup d'état du 15 au
16 juillet 2016 attribuée à la mouvance
islamique goulaine et une partie de
l'armée a été très dur elle a affaibli
les administrations civiles et
militaires dont l'armée de l'air mais
cette crise a aussi un style et une
méfiance sur le rôle des états unis avec
pour conséquence une ouverture vers la
russie
avec l'achat des missiles et 400 à
l'extérieur recep erdogan a trois
objectifs majeurs le pétrole les kurdes
et sa zone d'influencé pour combler son
coûteux des fichiers de pétroliers il a
récupéré en syrie le pétrole vendu par
des ch
puis on l'a vu en méditerranée
prospecter en dehors des zones
autorisées pour s'en retirer quand on a
découvert des gisements en mer noire
qu'il va enfin pouvoir exploiter
directement tout seul pour empêcher les
kurdes d'accéder à la mer il a obtenu
des russes et des américains le contrôle
de la région d'idlib en syrie qui est
devenu la zone de repli des djihadistes
et sa source de mercenaires pour ses
théâtres extérieurs comme on l'a vu en
libye en lien étroit avec le qatar il
s'est impliqué en libye pour soutenir le
gouvernement central proche des frères
musulmans
dans ce cadre il utilise sa marine pour
tenter d'étendre sa zone d'influencé en
méditerranée orientale
en continuation de sa doctrine de la
patrie bleus ce membre historique de
l'otan qui héberge la base militaire
dean cilic et de nombreuses stations
d'écouté américaine
reste soutenue par les américains comme
l'a prouvé le vote contre la france dans
la sphère de la frégate courbet ses
relations avec l'iran sont fluctuantes
dans un mélange de rivalité due à des
intérêts contradictoires en syrie dans
le caucase du sud et en asie centrale
mais également de coopération économique
étroite
ils sont il est vrai régulièrement
perturbés par des éliminations
d'opposants turquie par les services
iraniens comme le rappelle nous radu qui
dans le journal libanais l'orient le
jour du 21 décembre 2000 en syrie comme
l'expliquent un des meilleurs
connaisseurs de la région le journaliste
georges malbrunot le président bachar
al-assad peut remercier l'iran et la
russie d'être encore en place
même si c'est sur un champ de ruines le
président trump a décidé de laisser la
russie y contrôler la situation
militaire et maîtriser les velléités
indienne tandis que les émirats arabes
unis est sans doute la chine vont être
au coeur du financement de la
reconstruction du pays
accepté par les a rejetés par les autres
pour des raisons religieuses militaires
ou pour ses volontés expansionnistes
l'iran bénéficie d'une population d'un
peu plus de 80 millions d'habitants dont
le niveau de formation est supérieure à
tous ceux de la zone
il souffre évidemment des conséquences
du blocus imposé par les américains en
particulier pour la production de
pétrole est très nationaliste les
iraniens s'appuie sur un système qui
fonctionne mal et dont le guide suprême
l'ayatollah ali khamenei du malade
le remplacement par un civil ne semble
possible qu'avec une étape intermédiaire
exigeant l'appui des pasdaran qui
contrôlent beaucoup de domaines
d'activité dans le pays
dans ce cadre le meilleur candidat
semblait le général souleymane sy qui
bénéficiait d'une forte notoriété
personnelle son assassinat en irak par
un drone a rappelé aux irakiens et aux
iraniens que les américains pouvaient
intervenir à tout moment
par ailleurs la disparition du général
va permettre aux négociateurs américains
de se trouver devant des gens certes
compliqué manoeuvrier mais plus facile à
gérer parce qu'ils n'auront plus
derrière eux pour les piloter des gens
comme le général qui était à la fois
très dur et qui était parfaitement
rompus aux méthodes de négociation
occidental
l'avis de rappel il avait été confronté
aux occidentaux en irak et en syrie dont
qu'il connaissait très bien comment ça
fonctionne et pour les occidentaux
signataires de l'accord de vienne du 14
juillet 2015 et les israéliens
le problème iranien repose sur leur
forte volonté d'avoir l'arme atomique et
des missiles pour la transe
porter les iraniens constatant qu israël
la turquie le pakistan et l'inde en son
détenteur se sentent concernés et
veulent la réciprocité pour bénéficier
d'une capacité de dissuasion en dépit
des opérations menées par les israéliens
contre des installations nucléaires et
des éliminations de savants dont le
dernier fut le physicien mohsen
fakhrizadeh l'administration trump a
compris qu'elle n'arriverait pas à faire
changer le régime il n'arriverait pas
non plus arrêter le processus sans
négociation aussi choisi tel de créer de
graves difficultés à la population
civile par le blocus économique pour
obliger les iraniens a renégocié en état
de faiblesse
un accord qui soit plus complet
protecteur et contraignant que celui
signé par l'équipe du président obama
l'accord de troc avec les chinois dont
nous avons parlé dans une autre émission
lui permettant d'entamer les
négociations en meilleure posture
le président hassan rohani multiplie les
signaux d'ouverture
il est prêt à lâcher beau pour obtenir
la levée des sanctions et relancer
l'économie
mais en contrepartie ils demandent des
garanties dans la durée par rapport aux
concessions qu'ils devront faire car la
corse côté par tron devait inclure
également les zones d'influencé et
semble-t-il un accord secret avec israël
dans cette négociation qui intéresse
tous les pays de la région il est clair
que seuls les américains ont les moyens
d'exercer une pression suffisante et
donner de véritables garanties
le problème est maintenant de voir
comment je hebeisen va traiter le sujet
fort du soutien de 150 représentants
démocrates qui lui demandant de
réintégrer l'accord nucléaire sans
nouvelles conditions le président a
confirmé qu'il allait relancer les
négociations mais se contentera-t-il de
quelques améliorations du traité où
ira-t-il en ce sens de son prédécesseur
en négociant un nouvel accord plus large
et plus ouverts s'ils relancent l'accord
actuel les accords d'abrams resteront
une alliance stratégique contre l'iran
qu'une ira les pays de la région et
réglera les relations avec israël s'il
répond aux différents points évoqués ici
toute la zone se trouvera pacifiée après
72 en conflit loin des déclarations
agressives des uns et des autres nous
oublions pas qu israël et l'iran sont
les deux seuls peuples non arabes de cet
orient compliqué
le problème du nucléaire régler est
celui de la sécurité d'israël et de
l'iran garantie ils referont des
affaires comme par le passé des sunnites
se sentiront sécurisé avec un allié
israélien et un iran nucléarisé
de leur côté la turquie le qatar et les
émirats pourront développer leurs
relations commerciales avec le reste du
monde tandis que l'iran bénéficiera
d'une relance économique forte
il restera à régler le problème des
palestiniens les oubliés de l'histoire
qui devront se remettre en cause en
passant sous les fourches caudines d'un
accord entre tous les acteurs qui
imposera la paix des armes par l'arrêt
du financement de ces armes mais
également kir concentrera tous les
efforts de tous les pays de la région
sur le développement économique de la
palestine
il est évident qu'on ne peut pas
continuer comme aujourd'hui a encouragé
les débordements qui peuvent se passer
sur la bande de gaza ou en cisjordanie
et qui n'arrange personne en particulier
qui n'arrange pas les palestiniens dans
ce grand jeu
les etats-unis ont su tirer parti de
leurs atouts tandis que l'europe selon
le constat d'isabelle lasserre du figaro
se cantonne dans le rôle de spectateur
sceptiques en ayant totalement minimiser
la dynamique créée par les accords
d'abraham pourtant si tout se déroule
comme l'envisageait donald trump et ses
négociateurs 2020 n'aura pas été
seulement l'année de lakovic 19
mais comme l'a dit récemment dans un
colloque d'elne est à paris arie
bensemhoun elle sera aussi pour le moyen
orient
celle des accords d'abraham à bientôt
[Musique]